you know what Israel wants they want
them to be Dubai go be the Dubai of the
Mediterranean we wish you luck you know
who will benefit from that the
Palestinian people you notice he keeps
doing this hand motion pushing outward
because they went in and pushed everyone
out of their you know ancestral lands
kick them out and put at least the Gins
into an open air prison where they don't
have access to so when they keep saying
oh become the Dubai of the mediteran
they don't have access to materials to
off into enough food to clean water
there are so many reasons they cannot
quote unquote be the Dubai of that area
it's so laughable